- A couple of years ago,
I applied to the strategy
consulting firm, McKinsey.
And I got in.
In this video, I'm going to show you
the real CV that I used
to apply to McKinsey,
and that landed me the job.
This is no click-bait, guys.
I'm showing you the real thing,
the actual document that I handed in
when I submitted my application.
To those of you who don't know me yet,
welcome to my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and I'm
a former McKinsey consultant.
I worked with the firm for
about six years in the end,
serving as a project lead.
About a year ago, I
transitioned from McKinsey
into a C-level role at
a German retail company.
And I started this YouTube
channel, Firm Learning,
to talk about my experiences,
and my tips and tricks,
what you can do to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So without further ado,
let's jump into the CV.
I just have two introductory remarks.
The first is that I blacked out
a couple of personal information,
but all the rest, everything else,
this is really the document that I used.
The second is that,
because I applied to the
German office at that time,
my CV is in German.
And I did not want to now
tamper with the document.
So I'm showing you the
actual version, in German.
But of course, the whole video
is going to be in English,
and I'm going to explain you in detail
all the individual sections.
So trust you're going to get lots of value
out of this video, even if
you do not speak German.
This is it, guys.
This is the real CV that I
used to apply to McKinsey,
and I got in.
Let's now first go over
the overall structure,
and then we go over each
of the positions in detail.
So what you see is that here,
above, I have this
header segment of the CV.
Then I have a segment called 'Ausbildung',
this means education.
So these are all my university
degrees and things like that.
Then 'Arbeitserfahrung',
this means work experience.
Then 'Extracurriculare Aktivitäten',
this means extracurricular activities.
Then 'Stipendien', this
means scholarships.
And qualifications.
Let's now go over each of
these segments in detail.
And what I wanna say in the beginning is
that probably today,
I would make some of the
things a bit differently.
I wouldn't phrase those
things exactly like this.
I might do some changes to the structure,
but at that time, I
just didn't know better.
But let's start with the header,
here it's just pretty basic.
You see my name, you see my date of birth.
You see where I was born, and
then here my postal address,
as well as a telephone
number and an email.
Next, let's talk about
the education section.
So let's start at the bottom,
this is ordered anti-chronologically,
so the oldest position is here below.
And this was my high school degree,
Gymnasium Johanneum, this was
the name of my high school.
And what you see here
are my focus courses.
So in Germany, you can
choose a couple of subjects
that you really focus on,
I chose biology and social sciences.
And what I always included,
I just blacked it out,
just the GPA, the grade that I got.
Next is Universita
Commerciale Luigi Bocconi.
This is my exchange semester,
so I stayed one semester
at the University Bocconi,
which is, at least in Europe,
quite well-known business
school in Milan, in Italy.
Then my main university degree,
this was the university in Munich,
Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität.
And actually, what I
did was a double degree.
So I studied in two
independent bachelor programs
at the time, I studied
business administration,
that was the first one.
And then philosophy.
And as philosophy I had a minor in first
(chuckling) history of arts,
and later economics.
And again, I included here the grades.
And when I applied,
I was in the fifth semester
of my bachelor studies,
so I didn't complete these degrees yet,
but of course I had a GPA.
And then finally, a honors
degree in technology management,
at the Center for Digital
Technology and Management,
that was an honors degree,
an additional degree that you
were able to do in Munich,
which was focused on, as the name says,
technology and management.
And here again, I believe it
was still ongoing at that time,
so I included the current GPA.
So let's move to the next section,
and this is the section
on the work experience.
So what was the practical
experience that I had
when I applied to McKinsey, at the time?
And again, let's start
anti-chronologically.
Here the first one,
this was an internship,
internship is called
'Praktikum' in Germany.
And this was at Miele.
So Miele is, at least in Germany,
a pretty well-known company
that mainly is well-known
for kitchen appliances.
And this was an internship
I did between my high school
and the start of the university studies.
So I was there for about one month,
working in the customer
service department.
And I was working on a training platform,
an e-learning platform,
that they were currently putting together
to train all their technicians
all around the world.
Then after the first semester
of my business degree,
I did an internship at
Harry Rosen in Toronto.
Harry Rosen is a large Canadian menswear
premium fashion retailer.
And I rotated between
different departments,
I was at the point of sale,
but probably mainly supporting
the merchandise team,
among other teams.
Then both during high school
up to my first semesters in university,
I worked in my family business,
and I collected mainly
experiences in the buying team,
but also in the sales team.
We are a medium-sized company in Germany,
and of course, working
in the family business
is always a bit of a different experience
than working in any other business.
But still, for me, this was
very practical work experience
that I collected at the time.
Next, I completed an
internship at Accenture.
Accenture is a very
large IT consulting firm,
and now this was my first
very significant internship
that also went on for a couple of months.
And what I did here is, I
supported an SAP implementation
in a large technical client.
So I was part of the consulting team,
working on-site with the client.
And now this was really the
first time I experienced
what it was like to work in a
large international company,
both on the consulting side of things,
but then also at the client.
And this internship worked pretty well,
because then after the
internship finished,
I worked as a working student.
I worked just as a part-time job,
during my university
studies, at that client.
So all in all, this was almost half a year
of work experience, in parallel
to my university studies,
that I collected at Accenture.
Then later, I worked
with a technical company,
Telefonica, and this now
wasn't really an internship,
this was rather project work.
So this was coming out
of a university class,
where we worked together with Telefonica.
And then Telefonica
asked us to support them,
in their business development
team on a project work,
and we developed a business plan.
A business plan for a new product
they were thinking about launching.
And it was not only the business plan,
but we were working in an
interdisciplinary student team,
and we also had iOS developers.
We had actually computer science students,
who then built the first prototype,
(chuckling) that was really
running on our iPhones in iOS!
To really bring a first
vision of that product, live,
into our phones.
And then finally, I took on a regular job
with a professor,
with Professor Picot at
his university institute.
And I supported him in his research.
So this now was a real academic job,
I was supporting him with his papers,
with the research, in a research team.
So this was now for me getting to know
the academia side of things,
what all of this is like.
So let's now move to the
extracurricular side of things.
And again, let's start with the older one.
This was something I was doing
still in parallel to my high school.
And I was invited by Siemens, actually,
I got a scholarship from Siemens
to start university studies
in parallel to my high school studies.
So in the end of my high school time,
I started at a local 'Fachhochschule',
which is a university of applied sciences,
to take on some first business exams.
So this for me was a great opportunity
to already get to know what it's like
to study at university,
during my high school time.
And then a second large
extracurricular activity is,
that I had at the time,
that I worked in a youth organization,
of a large political party in Germany.
And I was the leader of the local chapter
of that youth organization.
So I blacked that out,
because I do not want to
talk about my political views
here in public, on YouTube.
But it was one of the very
large political parties
in Germany.
And this was actually
one of the things I did
that really gave me lots of input,
lots of things to talk about
in the personal impact interview,
in the interview where you are asked
to talk about your leadership experiences,
where you are asked to talk
about how you led teams,
how you worked together with teams.
Because as you can imagine,
this was also during
the election year, 2009.
Where we had lots of elections
going on at that year,
so there was really lots
of things to organize.
And this was really lots of
material that I could draw from.
Next is the scholarships section.
So at the time, when I applied,
I had the Cusanuswerk Scholarship,
which is one of the
large public scholarships
that you can collect in Germany.
And then Max-Weber Programm Scholarship,
which is conducted by
the 'Studienstiftung',
which is the German
national merit foundation,
I believe this is what the translation is.
So this is specific thing in Bavaria,
where you can then get it.
And these scholarships pretty
much provide funding to you,
for your university degrees.
But in Germany, they're
also well-regarded,
because the selection
process is quite complex,
with an assessment center
and things like that.
Which is why consulting
firms like McKinsey
usually tend to very much like this.
And then the Siemens scholarship
that I already talked about,
which enabled me to fund my studies
in parallel to my high school.
And then a section about
other qualifications,
and here I included my language skills.
This is of course English,
and I already did a
TOEFL test at the time,
because when I applied to McKinsey,
I already completed my TOEFL
for the Master applications
that I had out there.
And in the end, you maybe already know,
that then I ended up doing
a Master of Accounting and Finance,
at the London School
of Economics in London.
So the time sequence was
that I completed my
internship during my bachelor,
then I already received an
offer to join McKinsey later.
But then I first did this
one-year Master in London,
and then I joined
McKinsey after the Master.
So this is why I already
had the TOEFL test.
Then I spoke Italian, also
because I studied in Milan,
as I told you, for an exchange semester.
And then I had Latinum in high school.
And then I also included my GMAT score,
which, again, I already did
because I did these Master applications.
And then I included the computer skills
that I had at the time.
So that's it, guys, this was my CV.
This was the real document,
the real thing that I used at that time
when I applied to MBB firms like McKinsey.
And again, due to this application,
I got my job at McKinsey,
for an internship,
which then later got me the offer
to join in a full-time position.
Again, looking at it
from today's perspective,
While my current CV still
looks pretty similar to this,
there are a couple of
things that I would change,
now I talk a lot about, for instance,
quantifying your achievements.
This is certainly something
I didn't do enough
at that point,
but at that point in time
I just didn't know better.
If you still have any
question about my CV,
or my time at McKinsey,
please leave me a comment,
below in the comment box.
And please, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel
to see more content like that.
On my channel, I share
tips and strategies,
what you can do to be successful
in the first years of your career.
I talk a lot about my time at McKinsey,
about my experiences in consulting.
But many other career-related
topics as well.
And if you want to see even more from me,
follow me also on my Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
On my Instagram, I share new
content almost every day.
And last but not least, I
also have a mailing list,
where I share even more regular insights.
You will find a sign-up
link to the mailing list
below in the video description.
Thank you for watching, I
really appreciate your time.
I upload once a week,
at least every Saturday,
so stay tuned for next week,
for next Saturday's video.
And until then, a great weekend to you,
hope you're having a good time,
and see you soon, here on my channel.